[Musique]
m
quand les premiers hommes apparaissent
sur cette terre leur seul cadeau de
bienvenue l obligation à une lutte
mortelle pour la survie ils doivent se
battre contre des fléaux des fauves et
même entre père et fils car le combat se
poursuit dans chaque clan
alors comme chez des animaux le mal le
plus fort devient chef de tribu
les femelles s'offrent à lui pour
générer une descendance plus résistantes
et ceux qui s'opposent sont tués
c'est la loi naturelle du plus fort
avec une différence alors que les
animaux subissent les lois de la nature
les hommes au contraire s'ingénie à
plier ces mêmes lois à leur avantage
[Musique]
mais la loi du plus fort et dur
apprivoiser
les hommes forts se font encore plus
fort par les armes et les anciennes
écritures du monde sont un répertoire de
massacre
[Musique]
la vie n'a aucune valeur pendant des
millénaires
mais la pensée humaine collective
aboutie
enfin au premier acte d'équité à athènes
n'est la démocratie
ce régime politique rejette l'idée d'un
seul individu au pouvoir les citoyens
expriment leur opinion par le vote est
l'homme fort est remplacé par les
représentants de la majorité
[Musique]
c'est un système encore un parfait
puisque la majorité décide de son plein
gré au détriment de la minorité qui
n'est pas d'accord
mais la démocratie est un bon pas vers
plus de justice
tout change lors des guerres sanglantes
entre athènes et spa la démocratie
recule alors et la loi du plus fort
s'impose de nouveau entraînés au combat
les grecs colonisent les îles et les
côtes de la méditerranée
mais ils sont bientôt battu par les
macédoniens d'alexandre le grand
y arrivent jusqu en un sur les montagnes
de l'afghanistan vivent encore les cas
fine les descendants des militaires
d'alexandre rester en extrême orient
[Musique]
après les macédoniens
les romains sont les nouveaux champions
de la loi du plus fort
ils soumettent l'europe le maghreb et le
moyen-orient
formant lempire le plus fameux de
l'histoire
les romains arrive même en chine par un
trafic régulier de navires entre rome et
cantons où l'on trouve encore des
monnaies d'or et d'argent qui remonte de
l'époque d'auguste jusqu'à trajan
c'est l'empereur néron qui ouvre la
fameuse route de la soie
par cette route rome exporte en asie
l'alphabet le vert la clepsydre
le raisin les parfums et les pierres
précieuses de la baltique et de la
méditerranée par cette même route
rome importe de la soie
le thé chinois le papier
l'enfant
la poudre à canon
le fer forgé la porcelaine les perles
le jeu de cartes
les échecs
et même les spaghettis
[Musique]
si les romains sont gagnants par les
armes de gros problèmes de vie civile
apparaissent
[Musique]
les différents cultes des peuples soumis
qu aux incompréhensions et violence car
chacun veut imposer sa foi alors pour
mettre de l'ordre
l'empereur romain constantin décide que
l' empire doit embrasser une seule
religion déclarante hérétiques tous les
cultes sauf le christianisme constantin
se met d'accord avec le pape sylvestre
et se nomme chef de l'église chrétienne
centralisant le pouvoir politique et
spirituelle sur la seule figure de
l'empereur romain
[Musique]
l' empire romain est si vaste qu'il est
divisée en deux avec un empereur
d'occident et un empereur d'orient et la
pax romana règne pendant deux siècles
qu'en venant des steppes d'asie centrale
les uns d'attila mettre à feu et à sang
leur plein
des peuples germains s'échappe alors en
masse et pénètre dans l'empiré romain
d'occident pillant tout sur leur passage
cela favorise la rébellion des troupes
germanique enrôlé dans l'armée romaine
qui dépose l'empereur romain d'occident
et saccagent rome centre religieux de
lentilles
[Musique]
c'est le chaos les barbares riom
rome pourtant n'a aucune intention
d'abandonner sa suprématie
elle a perdu le pouvoir militaire mais
détient encore le pouvoir spirituel un
pouvoir si puissant que le roi des
germes à francs clovis à mesure le
paganisme et s'agenouillent face à saint
rémy pour se faire baptiser chrétiens
cette conversion vote à clovis le titre
d'empereur romain d'occident
le roi franc charlemagne le grand maître
de l'europe ça genou il lui aussi face
au pap pour se faire couronner empereur
comme les romains
[Musique]
la peur de dieu rend les papes si
puissant qu'il sacre les souverains
participe au gouvernement et peuvent
excommunié
c'est la loi du mentalement plus fort
mais un problème inattendu se pose
les peuples européens maintenant devenus
chrétiens refusent la violence
suivant la parole du christ certains se
font martyrisé plutôt que de rejoindre
l'armée et de tuer les ennemis
[Musique]
cela inquiète les souverains européens
toujours en quête de soldats pour leur
guerre ils font donc appel au pape
urbain 2 afin qu'ils trouvent une
solution alors sous prétexte de chasser
les sarrasins de jérusalem urbain de
inspirent les croisades et aux cris de
dieu le veut ils justifient la guerre
les savants de l'église explique que
pour justes motifs dieu permet le
meurtre et les moines templiers du don
les sarrasins vous rendre un service aux
crises
cette adversité vis-à-vis des musulmans
remonte à plus de trois siècles parce
qu'ils ont occupé la péninsule ibérique
le voisinage de cette religion
concurrentes et belliqueuse inquiète
drogue
[Musique]
elle sacre alors empereur du saint
empire romain germanique le très
puissant roi de germanie au ton premier
qui s'agenouille lui aussi face au bape
jurant sa protection à l'église
[Musique]
rome se libère enfin du voisinage
musulmans avec la reconquista des très
catholiques espagnols et portugais
qui débutent leur grand voyage maritime
se partageant l'amérique du sud où ils
massacrent les natifs pour voler leurs
offres les français aussi sont un peuple
européen très puissant possédant des
colonies en asie en afrique et aux
amériques leur général révolutionnaire
napoléon bonaparte bon qu'hier l'europe
et supprime le saint-empire romain
germanique rome n'a pas le temps de se
plaindre d'avoir perdu son empereur que
napoléon le chasseur de nobles et de
presse subit le charme de la couronne
impériale
[Musique]
il s'agenouille lui aussi face au pap
qui le couronne empereur des français
avec tous les fastes de l'ancien rome
[Musique]
non
les anglais par contre n'accepte pas le
pape de rome ils sont chrétiens
anglicans très riche et puissant
oh
inventeur de la bourse et de l'industrie
il colonise l'asie et nasri l'australie
et l'amérique du nord en exterminant les
natifs
[Musique]
les germains aussi sont très puissants
ils ont occupé l'europe au 6e siècle et
en effaçant les ibères des scènes et les
bretons ils ont donné naissance aux
peuples européens actuels les français
descendent des germains francs les
anglais des germains angle les espagnols
des germains wisigoths les italiens des
ostrogoths les suédois légèrement
vikings et ainsi de suite sur la terre
native des germains les allemands à eux
seuls effraye le monde entier lors de la
dernière guerre mondiale
l'europe est un véritable berceau de
pays puissants
[Musique]
il exerce la loi du plus fort depuis
3000 ans et ça remet toujours même en
temps de paix car l'histoire enseigne
qu'il est plus sûr d'être craint que
d'être aimé ainsi malgré la déclaration
des droits de l'homme par le biais du
cynisme politique de nicolo machiavel si
appréciée des gouverneurs moderne la loi
du plus fort déstabilise encore le monde
[Musique]
personne n'est en sûreté
malgré sa force de dissuasion l'europe
aussi est guetté n'osant pas la
soumettre par les armes des pays
d'autres continents déplace le conflit
au niveau économique
les etats unis sont l'un de ces pays
jadis terre des amérindiens puis colonie
anglaise peuplé de migrants européens et
d'esclaves africains la colonie anglaise
se rebelle contre la grande-bretagne et
proclame la république des états unis la
rébellion est financé par des nobles
anglais qui souhaitent rétablir lempire
aristocratique perdu en europe et le
transformer en empire financier aux
états unis
lors des guerres mondiales lempire
financier des états unis prospère grâce
à la production d'armes qu'il vend à
tous alliés et ennemis en échange d'or
c'est la loi du plus riche les états
unis offre l'aide économique du plan
marshall au pays effondré par la guerre
à condition qu'ils hébergent les bases
militaires américaines
[Musique]
devenue ainsi la plus forte puissance
militaire de la planète
il constitue alors l'onu et l'otan pour
intervenir militairement dans les
différents et achèvent leur contrôle du
monde mais les 800 bases militaires les
armes sophistiquées grève l'économie
il imprime alors des dollars au-delà de
leur disposition d'or s'endettant auprès
de la chine du japon et des paradis
fiscaux
[Musique]
le dollar est la monnaie la plus
utilisée au monde mais elle est
confrontée à la livre anglaise au franc
français au mark allemand et aux
monnaies d'asie d'amérique latine et
d'afrique
ces monnaies sont un danger pour les
états unis ils agressent alors les pays
riches l'amérique latine ou d'asie du
moyen-orient et d'afrique pour étouffer
leur économie en europe
les etats unis sont plus prudents ils
n'utilisent pas d'armes mais s'accordent
en secret avec l'allemagne pour
enchaîner les pays dans l'union
européenne
l'euro est en basé sur son marque
l'allemagne touche sa récompense et
s'enrichissent au détriment des autres
pays membres de l'union
[Musique]
la russie aussi est un adversaire de
l'europe pays le plus vaste de la
planète
la russie n'est d'un comptoir vikings à
kiev et pendant trois siècles subi
l'invasion musulmane de mongols tata
quand les tatars par le prince chrétien
orthodoxe de moscou
ivan le terrible annexe les territoires
limitrophes et se proclame d'art de
toutes les russies avec le titre romain
de césar le titre de cesar ne suffit pas
à pierre le grand qui considère la
russie comme la troisième rome succédant
à byzance
il se proclame alors empereur romain
sans passer par le pape de rome qui
n'est pas reconnue par les chrétiens
orthodoxes
[Musique]
l' empire romain russac fois en
puissance et cela ne convient pas à
l'allemagne et aux états unis qui
financent donc la révolution des
bolchéviques de lénine l'empereur atik
et lénine instaure la dictature
communiste
[Musique]
le communisme est un régime politique
prônant une société sans classe ni et à
la production est en adéquation avec les
besoins de la collectivité et la
propriété est abolie
cependant des millions d'opposants sont
exécutés dans un nouvel élan
impérialistes la russie communiste
forment l'union sovétique soumet les
pays de l'est de l'europe
installez missiles
r à cuba et envahit la somalie et
l'afghanistan mais sa dépense militaire
est insoutenable
l'union soviétique s'effondre et par la
pérestroïka la reconstruction et la
glasnost la transparence la russie
tourner la page
errant l'indépendance aux pays soumis
cependant la russie à un grand regret
l'ukraine
l'ukraine était jadis une région russe
et sa capitale kiev est le berceau
historique de la russie mais elle a
voulu l'indépendance alors dans le but
caché de la réintégrer la russie armes
les sécessionnistes ukrainien et annexes
la crimée par un référendum controversé
[Musique]
la russie est aussi un grand état tampon
entre l'europe et la chine communiste
qui avec son milliard et demi
d'habitants
l adversaire futur du monde entier le
président chinois s'était lui avis et
ambitionne de prendre la place des états
unis pour le contrôle du monde
[Musique]
alors les états unis remodèle les
équilibres planétaires et planifie la
dissolution de l'union européenne
devenue trop dépendantes des chinois
cette dissolution conviendrait à la
russie qui cligne de l'oeil aux petits
pays européens prêts à les engloutir
s'ils deviennent orphelins
à rome les papes non plus d'empereur a
sacré depuis le 16e siècle les
gouvernements européens se sont libérés
du clergé et sont devenus laïque les
royaumes sont devenus constitutionnel ou
république démocratique et la politique
a remplacé la religion les électeurs
sont les nouveaux croyants
les parlements sont des basiliques les
partis politiques remplacent les
congrégations religieuses les tox au son
des sermons et les isoloirs sont les
nouveaux confessionnaux
[Musique]
quant à l' empire romain il s'est
transformé en église catholique et garde
son hégémonie sur plus d'un milliard de
fidèles sa ville rome est bien assortis
à florence
venise au seigneurie de la renaissance
qui rivalisaient en art et en culture
[Musique]
tout cela s'arrête brusquement en 1861
avec la naissance du royaume du talion
les piémontais financé par le royaume
uni attaque que sans préavis les états
italien et annexes la péninsule italique
[Musique]
le pape pie 9 excommunie leroy
piémontais mais ne peut empêcher que le
saint-siège soit réduit à une enclave
dans la ville d'europe
les piémontais ravagent le sud de
l'italie
les patriots ont rappelé les brigands et
sont exécutés les banques du royaume des
deux siciles sont dépouillés et la
sicile est livrée à elle-même
[Musique]
face à la confusion les nobles sicilien
forment alors une organisation secrète
la mafia dirigés par des hommes
d'honneur la mafia à la mission de
rétablir l'ordre en sicile sicile le
négligé par l'état italien
même lors de la dernière guerre mondiale
[Musique]
cela convient aux etats-unis qui
cherchent un lieu sans défense ou
débarquer leurs troupes
il demande alors à la mafia sont aux
sentiments pour débarquer en sicile
sans trop de bruit en échange ils
offrent beaucoup d'argent et poste dans
le futur gouvernement italien et des
facilités aux états unis
c'est une offre qui ne peut se refuser
la mafia accepte et les fascistes sont
renversés mais la nouvelle génération de
mafieux ébloui par le pouvoir politique
se plonge dans le crime organisé se
tortillant comme les tentacules d'une
pieuvre la nouvelle mafia s'enrichit
dans les travaux publics et privés
impose un pourcentage aux entrepreneurs
et tuent sans délai les opposants les
délateurs et leurs familles
c'est la loi du plus cruelle
les militaires et les juges italiens qui
découvrent la négociation secrète entre
la mafia et les institutions sont
massacrés
c'est la guerre entre la sicile et
l'état italien
une guerre qui se termine quand la mafia
forme un parti politique à m
en apparence c'est un parti de droite
mais dans les coulisses avec tant
d'argent illégal a blanchi la mafia
corrompt tout le monde si bien que son
parti gagne les élections italienne mais
le chef du parti est un homme si amoral
que les grands de la terre indigné le
bli financièrement à s'éclipser au plus
vite de la scène politique italienne
c'est un coup d'état démocratique
sans revenir au vote des financiers non
élus s'installe du gouvernement italien
vendent les meilleures entreprises et
favoriser spéculation financière
la course à celui qui grappille le plus
se termine quand un mouvement de jeunes
populiste accuse la classe politique
d'avoir dépouillé le pays et remporte la
victoire aux élections italienne
[Musique]
ce mouvement pratiquer la démocratie
participative assistée par internet
au lieu de l'actuel démocratie
représentative qui élit les
représentants du peuple la démocratie
participative permet au simple citoyen
de participer personnellement à la vie
politique donnant son avis sur l'instant
jamais dans l'histoire de l'humanité un
individu n'a pu exprimer son point de
vue au monde entier laissant des traces
indélébiles
cette opportunité n'était réservé qu'aux
grands de la terre
amour avis le roi de babylone
fit traduire son code dans toutes les
langues connues afin qu'il soit lu
partout dans son empire mais ne pouvait
ni être lus ni interagir dans le monde
entier
aujourd'hui c'est possible
[Musique]
internet favorise la meilleure des
démocraties possible en temps de paix
en temps de guerre
comme à l'époque d'athènes ce parc la
loi du plus fort revient et alors
malheureux les faibles
et
[Musique]